[Music]
today i'm giving a webinar on
interactivity in production
this webinar is the third
in a three-part series that we've been
doing
last month garrett grollman delivered
reproducibility in production
and thomas mock delivered our studio
connect in production
those are freely available on demand at
resources.ourstudio.com the same place
this one will be
made available but before jumping in to
interactivity in production i wanted to
acknowledge some of the themes from
those first two webinars that i'll be
touching on as well
the first theme is production means
different things
to different people garrett talked about
this
tom talked about this really well with
our studio connect and how the connect
product
can meet you where you are and make
production
available in different forms with
different meanings to wherever you are
in your analytics life cycle
also along those same lines our studio
connect is this publishing platform for
communicating impactful data science
work
our markdown is a tool for creating
computational documents
and communicating impactful data science
through
either static reports or
documents that have interactive elements
inside them
and the one thing that i want to use as
a jumping off point
for starting our discussion today is
what garrett introduced in the
reproducibility webinar
which was the interactivity spectrum
so in in this interactivity spectrum
garrett made this case for thinking
strategically about what level of
interactivity
your data product actually requires and
meeting that level of interactivity with
the type of experience that you want to
deliver
in order to communicate effectively so
i really like this a lot but it does
kind of presuppose
that you know what you want to build in
the first place
or you're at a point in your iterative
development work cycle
where you're willing to do some
introspection on
what you should or could be building
this is important because as you
progress down
the interactivity hierarchy things
become more complicated to build and we
tend to
think of shiny applications the highest
level of interactivity
as the most complex to develop
now on the other side of things garrett
also
spoke to this in his webinar we tend to
see people learn shiny
and then use it for just a lot of things
borderline on everything and i know i've
done this and
it's very hard once you commit to this
shiny application
workflow or development cycle to walk
back
from shiny in other words once you've
committed to using shiny it's difficult
to take a step back
and evaluate whether you would be better
served
delivering your desired user experience
in another format
now all that being said i
love shiny so i want to talk about the
case for
starting with shiny because i know that
folks out there
do this too it's
you know it's a great tool it makes
things really
easy and it's a great tool for doing a
lot of things like
exploratory data analysis prototyping
fast iteration through building tools
that
that other folks might want to use and
that you can use to drive
impact of your data science work inside
of your own organization
now i'm no shiny wizard you can go and
look at
the the shiny contest results we ran
last spring to see evidence of actual
shiny wizardry but i'm comfortable
enough
with shiny that i can build really
powerful prototypes in a short amount of
time and i know
a lot of folks are in that same boat so
when i need to build a tool that other
people might want to use
too my natural inclination is to start
developing that tool
in shiny now these things can quickly
escalate
when you want to give access to someone
else to use that tool and that's what i
want to talk about
today i sort of think of
starting with shiny as the
equivalent of writing an hour-long
talk so i call starting with shiny and
local development as the hour-long talk
of data products and
you know hour-long talks if you've ever
developed one
can be rambling and cluttered you have a
lot of time to work with
so there can be parts that work really
well parts that
don't work so well and i know i'm giving
an hour long talk currently so
i hope that in the questions you'll let
me know which parts work well which
do not so that i can clarify those
but the goal is when you're taking this
local development asset into production
so you want to turn that hour-long talk
of data products
into the lightning talk of data products
so the difference between
hour-long talks and lightning talks our
our lightning talks are
these targeted really elegant
streamlined
little pockets of information that
you're trying to deliver
in a very short amount of time and the
irony
is that it can take a lot more time
of your own to develop a lightning talk
than i can to develop
an hour-long talk where you have a lot
of space to work with because those
lightning talks
they just need to have that that
streamline that
that concision you need to get to your
message
effectively and conclude everything
in the right amount of time so maybe you
start
with shiny and local development and by
the end
maybe in production that original
shiny application you had on your local
machine
looks very different maybe once you get
to production
it's a group of assets that complement
each other
maybe it's a very different kind of
shiny application as long as you're
evaluating
along the way starting with shiny in the
hierarchy of interactivity
is really okay by me
so this is my agenda for the webinar
discussion today
i started with making a case for
starting with shiny and now i want to
talk about
when you're taking a prototype of a
shiny application into production
what i consider the most important thing
is
and this is my perspective as a
solutions engineer at our studio
then i want to talk about joe chang's
most important thing for shiny and
production
joe is if you aren't familiar the cto
of our studio and he was the creator
of the shiny package
after that i want to talk about an
example a prototype app that i built
and then went through steps that joe
outlines in his performance workflow to
take that application
into production and along the way i'm
going to show you what steps i took to
refactor
and then evaluate the impact of that
application
and finally reconsider the hierarchy of
interactivity for what i've produced
so let's jump right into it this is what
i consider
the most important thing for running
shiny in production
and that is you need to have a sandbox
publishing
environment as part of your development
infrastructure
this thing right here you need it
it should be a place where you can
publish freely into
a server that is ideally configured to
be
an identical twin of your production
server
and this is your testing ground you can
call it a sandbox
staging test server whatever you need
one of these
if you only have one server at your
disposal
in a pinch even something like this can
work
you can have the same piece of content
be published to two different
destinations
on a single our studio connect box
and have one destination be you know
reserved for
production while the other destination
is reserved for
testing staging if you
need any help at all in your journey
to production advocating for the right
analytic infrastructure please reach out
to us
at solutions.ourstudio.com where there
are a bunch of resources for having
these conversations
or community.ourstudio.com in the r
admins channel and that's where a lot of
us on solutions engineering like to hang
out and answer questions coming from the
community
so two great resources there
so that was my my most important thing
joe has a very different
perspective and it's equally valid so
these are two
awesome opinions but joe's shiny in
production
most important thing he highlights
in this excellent talk that he gave
at our studio conf 2019 which is also
available
at resources.studio.com webinars
for you to watch this
talk is excellent and this is your
homework from
this webinar is to go watch joe's talk
if you haven't seen it already because
it is really that impactful
if you are doing anything that involves
shiny and production
so this talk was the keynote where he
introduced
the tools that our shiny engineering
team here at our studio
has been working on to help support
bringing
shiny into production so it starts with
going through shiny tests shiny load
tests profis
plot caching and async and he
highlighted
a couple of these tools throughout his
talk but
the thing that's most important to joe
is
profis for shining in production this is
a general profiler for our code but it's
like super important for when you're
bringing
shiny applications into production
a lot of prototype applications fall
over in production
because they contain these performance
anti-patterns
so uh it's important to
when you're trying to turn a prototype
into
a production application to ask yourself
questions
and suss out whether your application is
suitable for production in its current
state
so two questions you can answer
that are great is is this app
fast enough for production and then
if it's not what is the cause
of that performance bottleneck so
through the course of joe's keynote he
goes through and looks at
an example application called cran
whales that he
created and covered
you know how to make that application
faster
through the application of these two
tools shiny load test
to see if the app is fast enough
and profits to see
what in the r code is making that app
not fast enough so you lays out this
excellent performance workflow
which is the real gem here of this talk
uh you you ask if the app is fast enough
you test to see what's making it slow
and then
three is you optimize you solve those
problems
and the importance of using
profis is you can tell how passionate
joe is about this when he talks about it
and
in the keynote he he says you know you
cannot
guess at what is making your our code
slow
you do have to use this profiler because
your
intuition about what is making that code
slow
it stinks it's garbage it's not good
uh like even folks who are very
competent at building shiny applications
can get
tripped up by you know simply assuming
you know what the problem is
so profits is an amazing tool
to help you get to the optimization
stage and then make
real impactful changes to how your
your code works
so in the spirit of joe's talk and his
crayon wales
application success story i wanted to
build a similar application
for this webinar and i won't repeat the
performance workflow demo
that joe has already done in his
definitely go watch it it's really great
seriously
but i wanted to create this prototype to
start that would
realistically highlight some of those
same
or similar performance anti-patterns so
i have a crayon logs app that's called
the trending r packages app and here's
what it does
as you can see here in the screenshot it
has this table
it's a dt table and you can
see which our packages have been
trending
over the last period of time the top 10
and then click on each of these
applications to view a little bit of
metadata
about what that package is and
what it does so all this data is coming
from
the cran logs api project
uh plus a little bit of arvest
magic scraping metadata about each
package so the the workflow that it goes
through
is that i call out to the cram logs api
slash trending endpoint to get those top
10 trending packages
then i make 10 more calls to that cram
logs api to retrieve the download counts
for each package put that data into dt
here in the application and then i use
arvest magic to scrape out that metadata
about each package when at the point the
user clicks on it
so this app you know it makes sense
to me i'm constructing this data
as i go i'm not thinking about
scaling at this point works pretty great
in my local development environment
when i push it to my staging server it
works okay
but i can already tell that there is
some danger here
as as more users come to this
application i'm worried that it won't be
fast enough to support the number of
users
that i expect so at this point i think
to myself this would
be a great case to activate joe's
performance workflow and move
through shiny load tests and profis
to get the answers about whether my
application
is going to work in production and how
to fix it so that it does
so i'll spare you the the first two
points of the workflow again go watch
joe's talk for those and skip to number
three
uh where i'm optimizing my code
so at this point the number one thing
that you do very often to optimize some
of these performance
issues is to move work out of shiny
and joe says there are two important
things
to consider when you're moving work out
of shiny
things that you don't want to do so you
don't want to do work
and shiny while the user is waiting
and the second thing is you don't want
to do the same work
for every user that's very wasteful so
he had this example of loading
the csv data into a shiny application
every time a user connects and
in this application i actually designed
for the purpose of highlighting these
two anti-patterns
but it does a very similar thing
uh i am making 11 api requests to the
trending
our packages table to create that
data for the user and then
once a user is on the application
i'm calling arvest two times
to perform uh that metadata scraping
for each row selection that occurs
so that would be repeating uh that same
work over and over again
for every user which again
very wasteful so how do we solve this
problem
there are a number of ways i can think
of to
to solve this i could generate the data
ahead of time and publish it in the
bundle
along with my application code and
this is a totally valid workflow and
it makes sense to do for a lot of
different types of shiny applications
sometimes you can just
pull the data together and throw it in
that bundle
and send it along as you're deploying to
staging to production and it's fine
the problem here is that i want users to
see the latest and greatest trending r
packages it's like
it's literally an application to explore
trends
so i don't want to get stuck manually
deploying
that new data or cobbling together or
some sort of cron job
coupled with a programmatic deployment
workflow that
i then need to monitor and make sure
continues to work
i just want new data delivered
to my shiny application that users can
see
you know fresh information about anytime
they visit the app
so this is a great case for
adding our markdown to the equation i
call this the division of labor
using our markdown to create
an etl process to put that data together
and then host an output file
along with that report that i can then
point my shiny application
to consume so if you don't know uh
content deployed to an endpoint on our
studio
with an our markdown output metadata
output file in this case in the case of
this image
i have this report uh called report
title
very descriptive and it has an output
file that contains this data.csv
file so in the course of this report
running it creates this
this data.csv file writes it out
and then it just gets hosted on our
studio connect
alongside by our markdown report so if
i'm running that report
on a schedule that that schedule is
producing this new data.csv file
that lives at this web address and then
i can
point shiny to read in that data from
the url hosted on my
connect server so very cool
and that's exactly what i want to do for
this application in order to move that
work
out of shiny and do it somewhere else
so that it doesn't have to be in my
shiny code itself
so this is what i built my r markdown
etl
to generate this same data frame out of
the
making calls to the trending api and
then
making those arvest web scraping
function calls
and i do this all in an arm markdown
document
publish that document to connect and
then i schedule it to run
weekly every friday at a certain time
and i could schedule that to run
you know daily or monthly or hourly
whatever whatever schedule i want to
produce new data on
i can do that directly in the r markdown
uh
hosted on our studio connect in in the
dashboard panel
that i'm showing here so really
really nifty uh tool to
create output data files
so now i have these three pieces of
content here
living as my production development
package and i'm happy with the
performance of my shiny application
because i've moved that work
out of shiny and into this etl process
so i have my production assets being
the ctl in our markdown my production
application
in shiny which is now fast and doesn't
repeat work for each user
and then a third asset which is not
really a part of it but it is fun to
publish alongside as
reference information which is the
profis profile
for that production application so all
of these three things can live together
and be a package that i can
feel confident about running on my
production server and
and serving my users effectively
so at this point you know am i done am i
making an
impact at my organization through what i
built
how do i answer that question is what i
built
correct uh you know i have these two
data products
shiny and r markdown working
harmoniously together
um is there anything else to do
so i i'd like to take a stab
at trying to quantify or track
impact on our studio connect with my
assets
so how do i know that what i've built is
effective
at communicating my intended message
the whole goal here was to create
something useful
and to drive users to
find you know insights through this tool
or
or make changes to how we do work at our
organization
through communicating that
in shiny in our markdown so am i doing
that
well there's also tools for getting
that data off of your rstudio connect
server and that is through
usage of another api called the rstudio
connect
instrumentation data api and
this is a really cool feature that
connect has
that i think is is underutilized and so
i want to use this talk to
to encourage you to look at some of the
resources we currently have
for uh you know visualizing this type of
data
on your connect server if you have
access to a connect server
and explore different variations
of building tools that can give you
insights into how much
impact you're actually making through
these data products so our studio
connect records different types of user
activity for
different types of content you've got
records for shiny applications about
each visit to that application and the
duration
of that visit and then you have records
of each visit for static and rendered
content
this dashboard you see here on the right
is one that my colleagues on solutions
engineering put together called the
connect
usage dashboard and it is available at
that github
url the code is all there and we would
really encourage you to
take that you can drop it into your own
server as
is if you'd like to see this same
information
about your data products or you can
tweak it
and make it custom to see or gather
information that will answer your own
questions
i've really been having a fun time
lately tweaking
this same instrumentation dashboard that
my colleagues put together
and turning it into something that i can
answer questions about
individual apps so this is the same
dashboard driven by the same you know
helper functions that they created
but i've tweaked them just to look at my
production application
and i want to know you know whether this
app
is popular or whether this app is just
not driving traffic it's not being
visited
and i want to take actions based on the
answers to those questions
so if this application is popular
that's awesome i want to go to the
runtime for that application i want to
evaluate my load test
and make sure that i have the right
settings for our processes and
connections for process
so that my user base is being served
there
and if the application is this not
driving traffic
it's not getting visits i want uh
this dashboard which is an our markdown
report
to send me alert and alert about
that information as well this this app
it's not driving
the desired uh impact at the
organization
so maybe i need to rethink what's
happening there
i built this application so that you can
come in
and set a daily visit goal
and then set a session duration goal
and you'll see here that based on the
inputs that
i have provided my application uh
production app this cran logs trending r
packages app that i'm tracking here
isn't hitting the total session goal
for daily count but it is hitting the
average session duration goal
so one not so good one pretty good
and the these value boxes will change
color
based on whether or not i'm hitting my
goals
behind the scenes what you don't see
here is that
this report also contains code to create
a custom email alert
excuse me based on
these value boxes as well so if over
time i see that i'm just
not driving the traffic to my
cran logs application that i wanted this
report will capture that data
and send based on what it finds
it'll make a conditional
decision to send me an email alert about
my underperforming app or suppress that
email
so in this case it might send me an
email
because my app is underperforming and
that email
is based on a custom template that i
packaged along
with my our markdown report and it looks
something like this
so i can have uh this
email come in and say hey for this
application title
um you know we've seen that traffic has
been chronically low
you might want to consider communicating
the same information
if it's still relevant in another format
so think about you know whether or not
somebody is still interested in
interacting
with your shiny application you know
is this the right method of
communicating
or why is this tool not having the
impact
that i wanted to sometimes web
interactivity
gets old like somebody will come to the
dashboard
play around with it once or twice but
you know it's not that much fun or
interesting to click around
and they would rather have that same
information
delivered to their inbox on
you know some sort of schedule
so that they don't have to go through
the work of interacting with a shiny
application as funny as that sounds
going taking taking the steps to go to
the connect server
and remember to do that you know are
steps that some folks in your
organization
maybe upper management or just you're
just not going to take the time to do
and so
thinking about tailoring the experience
to your audience is a really important
part of that whole process
when you're evaluating what you put into
production
should continue to exist there so
some things you might want to consider
to sacrifice
shiny run time in order to achieve our
you can have that that parameterized our
markdown that we've seen in previous
uh webinars that gets scheduled sends
custom emails like this one to your
management
scheduled email report delivery it just
said
and then a third asset that we didn't
really talk
too much about in this series is
creating
programmatic access to
communicate insights through the plumber
package and developing
rest apis so all of these things
are perfectly excellent alternatives to
creating more shiny interactivity
but they do take effort in order to
you know context switch and refactor
the code that you've you've invested
time and energy to create
in producing an alternative asset
but i think overall it's definitely a
worthwhile
process to go through and uh
that brings us back to the hierarchy of
interactivity
so i think my key takeaway here
is is definitely think about
how you want to tailor your experience
to your audience
and in the process of doing that
remember
that you know shiny applications
do come at a cost of complexity
you do need to iterate through joe's
performance workflow in order to move
prototype applications into production
ready applications and in order to get
through
all of that i would point to these
production building blocks that we
have made available in different
resource formats here at our studio so
again
one more shout out to joe chang
and the r studio conf keynote from 2019
it's an excellent talk about shiny and
and then individually
we have resources that exist on either
subdomain sites
that we maintain here at our studio or
or open source package reference sites
that
are also available on github and
externally
to the rstudio website on code profiling
through profits
general information on version control
which is also an important
aspect of of production testing
through the shiny test package thinking
about
deployment and release patterns
and for that these resources come from
thought uh articles that we've put on
solutions.studio.com access and security
for those applications
also on solutions.ourstudio.com
and performance tuning looking at the
results of
shiny load tests and making tweaks
to your application code and to
your application runtime settings based
on what your goals are
so i hope you've enjoyed this brief
discussion
of you know thinking about the
interactivity hierarchy when it comes to
building
assets that include interactivity like
shiny and putting them into production i
hope that you go and check out some of
these resources
and then continue the discussion with us
at
community.ourstudio.com as well
so here's one that says uh what if we
don't have
a subscription to shiny connect
so if you don't have our studio connect
there are good alternatives you can
always stand up and open source shiny
server
as long as you have the the requirements
to do so
and we have plenty of resources on shiny
datastudio.com
about how to get started doing that and
a lot of these tools for putting shiny
into production
with the open source server will still
apply
and some will be more difficult to
implement
but you know either way there there is a
path
to doing shiny
sharing shiny assets um
without our pro products let's see
what is required to be able to share a
shiny app with co-workers who do not
have
our studio so today i talked a lot about
um a product called our studio connect
and
i'm sorry if i didn't put a lot of
context around
that you you should definitely go and
watch
tom mock's webinar from two weeks ago
called
our studio connect in production but
like i said
even if you don't go the route of our
studio connect we have
other tools from our studio like shiny
server open source
or even shiny server pro if you're
interested
in alternatives there
here's one that says could gr
could the workflow just described be
done with a
separate shiny app run on a schedule
rather than the r markdown dock
now um shiny applications
don't natively
work running on a schedule
and you have to interact with them or
have
some sort of programmatic trigger to be
able to
do that and they definitely don't run on
a schedule on our studio
connect so if you are trying to
run an etl process on our studio connect
the choice for that would be our
markdown
do the profiling tools work for
shinyapps.io as well
what are the considerations there yeah
so profis is just a general r
profiling code tool so you can
definitely
use that for our code you can use it for
shiny code and you interact with it on
your local side so you're just
profiling that code in development
on the rstudio ide or on our studio
server
and then you're using that information
to tweak your code which then will end
up
living on shinyapps.io or
one of the other service products
yeah so that's that's a great question
and
is kind of the the problem that joe
addresses with the cran whales app and
his talk
and just get reloaded so
that does the data get reloaded whenever
a new user opens
the web address and that's going to
depend
on where you've put that action
in your code so you definitely don't
want to reload
the data for every user and
you probably want to try to
utilize a drill down approach for
exposing access to
more data as it's required for that user
if possible we have a great example of
building an enterprise dashboard with
that drill down approach that my
colleague edgar put together
on db.rstudio.com that's
db for databases.rtstudio.com
so that could be a really helpful
resource for you
when you're trying to build an
application
that loads a large amount of data
thanks so much
you